I want to talk to you about the universal basic income.
What do you think about,
what do you think about artificial intelligence and artificial intelligence and
automation and the removal of all these jobs is a real concern that a lot of
people have.
And then the,
the way to mitigate it that's being bandied about is universal basic income.
That they would give you a certain amount of money.
And I think the idea is that everyone would get it,
even wealthy people would get it.
And that would be the only way to make it fair.
But where the fuck is that money coming from?
And then what do you think about it?
I don't think it,
I,
I'm,
I'm not an economist man.
Right.
You know,
but I don't,
I don't think it's feasible,
at least right now.
I do believe that on a technological level we will eventually reach like a star
Trek,
you know,
kind of future where it's not about communism.
It's just literally like we have w a scarcity is gone,
like they have replicators.
But when it comes to universal basic income,
people need to understand some basic economic principles.
If everybody gets $1,000 okay,
that's 300 million thousand dollars.
Right?
But it's not everybody.
It's everybody of working age,
right?
Yes.
So,
so let's,
let's,
let's do this.
I wondered,
I own,
uh,
I own a burger shop.
I need to hire someone to flip burgers.
So I say we pay 10 bucks an hour.
It's a,
it's not,
it's not a lot,
but we're a small business.
We can't really afford to pay more.
It's acceptable.
They say,
I get 1000 bucks a month.
Why would I,
why would I spend,
you know,
if,
if you know that,
not really.
Well,
the idea is that the thousand bucks a month that you get,
you get to keep,
and then the,
my time is worth more than 10 bucks an hour.
I don't care.
When I,
when I was 17,
18,
I worked for American Eagle Airlines.
I was lifting like 50,000 pounds per day and I was getting 10 bucks an hour.
You might have been jacked.
No,
I,
well,
I was,
I,
I've been skateboarding my whole life,
so I was certainly,
you know,
in shape.
But if you gave,
if you told me,
hey,
you know how you're making less than a thousand bucks a month working fulltime
after taxes,
how about we just give you 1000 bucks?
I Bet I'll be at the skate park.
Yeah,
I'll be,
I'll,
you know,
so there's some positives that people will pursue their passions,
but hold on.
How many people do you know want to be comedians and they're not funny?
Quite a few.
And imagine if you said,
we're going to subsidize your endeavor into a thing.
You're not good at how many people are really good at copying and carpenters,
but they wished they'd be pro football players.
How many people are really good at being teachers,
but want to be a famous actor?
So what do you think would be some sort of an appropriate response to automation
and artificial intelligence?
You can't just have millions and millions of people just have no words,
you know,
and that's,
that's a quagmire.
This,
this is why I,
uh,
you know,
I've,
I've never been a pot smoker.
Uh,
I think I smoked like once in my life.
I want to try it now.
No.
Uh,
it's just not my thing,
but everyone always would think I was stoned because I would talk about this
kind of stuff with my friends while they were stoned.
The philosophical consequences of technological innovation,
it is not the postmaster's fault that he spent 30 years becoming the best of the
best in working at the post office.
That technology emerged that is going to displace him and make him put him in
the poor house.
Right when I was about 19 years old,
I was skateboarding in downtown Chicago and I saw an old black homeless man and
I had some leftover food and I was like,
Hey,
what's up dude?
You want some food?
And he was like,
aw,
thanks man.
And I was just like,
I got to know,
can I ask you a question?
How did you become homeless?
And he said,
uh,
you know what man?
He's like,
I think he was like 60 something.
He said,
I used to have a job.
Uh,
I worked all day.
Every day.
I had a family.
Uh,
eventually,
you know,
um,
my,
uh,
didn't have kids.
My friends started to get old and move on.
I lost touch a lot of them,
some of them died and one day I got told that my job wasn't needed anymore and
so I couldn't do anything.
Went on unemployment for a little bit,
but my,
you know,
the job I was good at,
it didn't exist.
Right.
I can't remember exactly what he said.
There's this 14 years ago,
but he was like,
so everywhere I went,
I said,
you know,
I'll do anything.
But even the,
the small jobs that pay a little bit to flip burgers weren't enough to cover my
rent.
After a few months,
I got evicted then because I didn't have a place to live.
I couldn't go to the job.
I did have.
I started sleeping outside and I've been here ever since.
And I'm like,
that said,
you know,
and that's,
that's,
that's the sad reality.
What do you do?
I don't know.
The EOC hooks you up,
but that's the thing.
She goes too far.
But this is why I believe in,
in some kind of social policy and safety net social security,
something to help these people.
Well for sure.
You know,
if we have a real community,
you wouldn't help out the people that are in your community or twig.
Yes.
You know,
you know communism works really,
really well when you have like five people.
I try explaining to people,
they always make this political,
uh,
you know,
the political compass,
authoritarian libertarian left,
right?
And they,
they,
people like to claim that anarchists like the violent smashy ones and Antifa are
libertarian left.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
Like the libertarian left quadrant,
our pot smoking hippies live on farms and arco communism makes a ton of sense.
When it's you and your buddies working together on a farm sharing
responsibilities,
it doesn't make sense for a community of 300 million people and you have to
trade extremely specific resources to make a computer happen.
Right.
At that point,
do you need to be able to quantify the value of specific objects?
And that's why communism doesn't work for massive,
massive scale.
But
I will say when,
uh,
artificial intelligence is a different conversation,
you know,
technological advancements,
advancement is going to result in like luddite riots.
And you know,
people,
you know,
the opioid crisis,
I could be wrong,
I read that there was a connection between unemployment from these factories
getting shut down and depressed dudes popping pills.
There was a,
uh,
a masculinity report was published by Harry's,
the shaving company,
and they said the over the overwhelming majority of what contributes to a man's
happiness as gainful employment,
like,
like 80%.
So what happens when a factory shuts down?
You got a bunch of young dudes who want to do something.
They want to matter,
but they can't.
There's no,
there's nowhere to go anymore,
especially in a small town.
But I'll tell you what,
man,
percosets feel real good.
You know,
those drugs,
they feel fantastic,
but they'll kill you.
So that's,
you know,
I think this contributes to the popularity of Bernie Sanders and Trump.
They talked about the working class.
I talked about these free trade agreements,
hurting people.
They talked about getting the factories back together.
And that means a lot to people who have been popping pills,
who are depressed,
who are sad and scared,
and it's a lot of people in this country.